Prince Andrew is reportedly standing by
his decision to do what turned out to be
a widely criticized interview about his
friendship with convicted sex offender
Jeffrey Epstein the Prince sat down for
a rare interview with Emily Maitlis for
the news night program at our partners
the BBC the Prince denied allegations he
had sex with a 17 year old girl who says
she was trafficked by Epstein and he
discussed his friendship with Epstein
who died in August in a jail in New York
City do I regret the fact that he has
quite obviously conducted himself in a
manner unbecoming yes I'm becoming he
was a sex offender yeah I'm sorry I'm
being polite of in the sense that he was
a sex offender
but no was I right in in in having him
as a friend at the time I'm bearing in
mind this was some years before he was
accused of being a sex offender
I don't think there was anything wrong
then the problem was the fact that once
he had been convicted he stayed with my
stable and that's that's that's the bit
that as it were I kick myself for on a
daily basis because it was not something
that was becoming a remember the royal
family Emily Maitlis joins us now in her
first u.s. interview since her interview
with Prince Andrew which aired Saturday
Emily good morning thanks for being with
us
morning my pleasure in the headlines in
the British press this interview is
being called a train wreck and a
catastrophic error why do you think the
Prince agreed to do it well I think to
be fair that what we got from Prince
Andrew was authenticity and there were
many figures that come on to the
television or give interviews to the
press who tend to be PR to distraction
everything is very carefully worded and
there is no wriggle room with anything
they say to ask anything else and this
was a different kind of interview we saw
an authentic side to the Duke of York
there were words that I'm guessing
he might want to have rephrased you
heard some of them in the clip that you
just played but this was essentially a
man who was engaging with every single
question that we put to him from news
night and my sense of why he did it was
because the question surrounding his
friendship and indeed his own conduct
sexual conduct had intensified following
the death of Epstein in August
the prince's PR advisor reportedly quit
over his decision to do this and you say
Prince Andrew sought approval from the
Queen do we know whether the Queen was
actually on board with this what we do
know is that he sought approval from
higher-up shall we say now he didn't say
to me directly that that was the Queen
but it's hard to think of who else is
higher up whose approval he would need
what I can tell you is that we filmed
the interview in the quarters of
Buckingham Palace that are very much the
Queen's own residence her entrance the
south drawing-room the marble hall where
they do the investitures if he hadn't
had the approval of the palace I'm
imagining it would have been done in a
sort of boardroom of a London hotel
somewhere
Virginia Roberts you Frey has accused
the Prince of having sex with her three
times while she was underage
he denies ever having he denies he says
he doesn't recall ever meeting her let's
listen to exactly what he said I have no
recollection of ever meeting this lady
none whatsoever you don't remember
meeting her
she says she met you in 2001 she dined
with you she danced with you you bought
her drinks you're in Trump nightclub in
London and she went on to have sex with
you in a house in Belgravia belonging to
Guerlain Maxwell didn't happen she was
very specific about that night she
described dancing with you and you
profusely sweating and that she went on
to have possibly there's a slight
problem with with with with with the
sweating
because I have a peculiar medical
condition which is that I don't sweat or
I didn't sweat at the time and that was
machine yes I didn't sweat at the time
because I had suffered what I would
describe as an overdose of adrenaline
and the Falklands War when I was shot at
and I simply it was it was it was almost
impossible for me to sweat
Emily how is that explanation being
received well with a certain amount of
interest perhaps incredulity in some
quarters I think we could say there was
no shortage of detail in the princes
answers I mean I think that's what comes
forward we were hearing things for the
very first time I don't know of that
medical condition I haven't you know I
don't have a medical background I
haven't researched into it but certainly
from Prince Andrews perspective he was
telling us things that he hoped would
make sense of what we'd seen of what
we'd heard of the allegations a lawyer
for Epstein's victims is calling for the
Prince to answer questions under oath in
the US do you think it's likely that he
could get drawn into a criminal
investigation I did put to him I asked
him if he'd be willing to answer
questions under oath and he said he'd be
willing to do what anyone else should do
he would take I think his words were
very serious legal advice on it and it
wasn't something he'd avoid if he had to
do it alright Emily Maitlis thank you
very much for being with us this morning
my pleasure thank you